i spent my entire life in your shadow
and now
you spend the rest of yours
living in mine
[Music]
no
no as i as you get older
you start to question your sanity
when you think about all the stunts that
you've done and never questioned
my whole process of
going into character
is
if if the director
tells me to jump off a building i'll
jump i'm worried that i'll jump off a
building because i go so deep in the
character so no an answer to your
question
uh
no stunt is too great
um and thank god
and let me take this moment to say this
thank god that i have such a great
stunt team
uh action sequence team because they
are so good at
preparing weeks or sometimes months in
advance to create that effect that you
see for seconds on screen
[Music]
oh no you're right i
i remember we used to after every fast
and furious movie at every
at every press jump that someone would
ask how many cars
but after
nine films you almost
you almost don't even want to hear the
number of cars that have gone in
to
creating these action sequences because
you almost can't count anymore um so
yeah so i guess i should wear that title
with a badge of honor and at the same
time say sorry to the world for uh all
the to the car universe for all the cars
that have gone and sacrificed their
lives for your entertainment
[Music]
it wasn't my idea
it was something that justin lynn
thought of and uh it was kind of
brilliant but kind of
difficult in some ways because it's not
i wasn't able to
sit behind the monitor and coach him
he had to do it himself he had to
rehearse with the other actors he built
the camaraderie with the other actors he
built his own brotherhood with the young
jacob and his own relationship
with jack tereto in that scene
i was very very very very proud
of the way that he approached his work
and i and like i said
i was in
the moment i was committed to the scene
from a more
emotional reflective place
so i was i had he had to do it on his
own so i was very proud that he was not
only able to do it on his own but most
importantly i was proud of the
dedication
that he put
in to
playing
the role
[Music]
if you would have asked me 20 years ago
if in 2021
we would be releasing a thousand viewers
with
dom being a father on a ninth chapter
i would have thought it was crazy i
would have thought it was unheard of
as you know
this franchise didn't have comic books
that you could or books or novels that
were pre-written it's a totally original
ip
i'm very proud of the fact that
universal has supported following the
evolution of these characters that have
been adopted by the world
i'm very very very proud of that
[Music]
dom has been that character synonymous
with family
when we think of dom
we think of
someone that's never turned us back on
family someone that promotes that
someone that believes in family
either by blood or by bond and what we
realize is when we go back to that first
scene in fast and furious where he's
talking to brian o'connor about that
charger and why he's so scared to death
of his father's car
we have no idea how deep it runs for dom
and we have no idea that it also
references not only the loss of his
father
but the loss of his brother because of
that broken brotherhood with jacob and
himself it was very deliberate to
contrast that with the return of han a
brother of doms for
15 20 years as we know at the end of
fast and furious diamond bryan split
ways one will continue to be a cop
one will continue to be an outlaw
but during those moments of
being an outlaw the brotherhood that he
had was with han as we see later in the
franchise but that was a very deliberate
note to show you how broken the
brotherhood of the past was and compare
it to the brother the to the joy
of seeing his brother han
[Music]
oh my god
that is uh that's a
my god that that question will take
hours to answer
i don't think people realize that
something we've always done in fast and
furious and it might sound crazy but we
audition cars like one would audition
hackers because every every car is
supposed to represent something an
extension of a character in the movie
and an extension of a state of mind of
that character where that character's
state of mind is at the moment so
it's one of the one of the funnest
things about starting fast is when we
audition the cars
[Music]
you know
it's a great question and a question i
wish i could just
give a
quick answer to
but i will say
i started acting when i was seven years
old and when i started acting
my father
not unlike dom's father's love for cars
and dom's obvious love for cars is
similar and passed down
my father had a love for acton
and pass that down to me at dinner there
would often be
other thespians other actors of his
generation
part of the actors studios part of
method acting
and he recently said to me no one of
that era would have ever anticipated
playing a character
in a movie
for over 20 years
and not playing a character in a movie
where you could
disregard the chronology
of the character or the evolution of the
character but to play a character you
knew
dom before he was a father you were also
watching my work in fast and furious
before i was a father it's fascinating
how both are intertwined i've learned so
much
from dom and dom has learned so much
from then
[Music]
uh
a peaceful life is nice a nice uh
a life in the country is very
beautiful they're compelled right i mean
ultimately the they realize in order for
them to have a peaceful life the world
needs to be right and that's what
motivates them into action i guess i
like it all i mean fast and furious
gives me
all the adrenaline i need making that
movie and being a part of that franchise
or any of the action films that i do
give me so much adrenaline that when i'm
not doing that a peaceful life is a
beautiful thing it's like people often
think about all the horrible things
about the last year the pandemic that
we've all
gone through together but my god i will
never forget
how lucky i am
to have spent every day with my children
and my family
and for the first time in a long time
that i didn't have to spend most of the
year on a set and i was just able to be
there for all of my children's birthdays
and be there while my children are
learning and be there to watch
the the best of my life grow
[Music]
i
miss that so much when you're making a
movie it's not
so i like i said before i grew up in the
theater
when you're performing on stage you get
immediate gratification you immediately
see what your work does
when you're making movies you're
isolated making movies and you have to
wait a year until you can hear the
reaction of your work i
love that about going on tour and
celebrating something that we've been
working on for years in fact the
philippines
is one of the top three premier
experiences i have ever had in my life
because it was so electric because it
was so
spectacular there's so much love
and that was at the time where we had
just finished fast five
we were just coming back with fast six
the audience was just beginning to
feel confident that we would show up
every two years like a holiday
[Music]
you